twilight made our hearts twinkle with
excitement in 2005 but when the cast hit
the big screen in 2008 we couldn't help
but wonder do the actors and actresses
really match the character descriptions
in the books for the most part
true fans disagreed i hate this
i hate what they've done to you today
we're going to be taking a look at
everyone's favorite vampires versus
werewolves saga twilight kristen stewart
and robert pattinson will forever be
remembered as twilight's iconic couple
not only for the nostalgia that
surrounds twilight but because of just
how good the casting was compared to the
characters in the book but
was the casting on point for the other
actors and actresses in the five film
saga
in today's video we're going to be
comparing the on-screen cast to the
character descriptions found in the
books
age physical differences and unfortunate
cgi
are just a few of the problems with the
on-screen portrayals
robert pattinson wasn't the first in
line to play edward they wanted to pick
henry cavill instead
difficult to believe anyone else could
portray the dreamy edward cullen but it
was close
initially twilight creator stephanie
mayer wanted henry cavill to be bella's
sullen romantic interest but backed out
on the decision due to henry being a
little older than she was aiming for
and instead you know a very talented
actor played instead although both
actors have us drooling
robert pattinson definitely matched the
description in the book
lanky less bulky with untidy bronze
colored hair he was more boyish than the
others
his face was absurdly handsome he looked
like he just finished shooting a
commercial for hair gel
we think this description is pretty spot
on especially the absurdly handsome part
beautiful this is the skin of the killer
bell
kristen stewart had to wear contacts
throughout the whole saga
throughout twilight kristen was tasked
with wearing brown contact lenses for
every shot
being naturally green-eyed and in order
to match bella's character perfectly
kristen agreed and initially had no
problem that was until the vampire
lenses came into play which robert
pattinson
also commented on being terribly
uncomfortable when you're trying to like
you're poking your eye for 20 minutes
later it's not the most pleasurable
experience
aside from the contact lenses though
kristen stewart was a perfect choice for
playing bella her ivory skin
slender figure and awkward disposition
was exactly how she was described in the
book
it wasn't until after twilight that we
realized just how awkward kristen
stewart is in real life but hey if the
contact lens fits
please don't happen mickey reed had to
wear a wig
in order to transform from natural
brunette to blonde vampiris
rosalie hale nikki reed underwent a
gruelling 36-hour process to dye her
hair
the problem her hair started falling out
which is clearly a problem
to stop premature baldness production
decided to move forward with nicki
wearing a blonde wig for the remainder
of the saga
and i looked at my wig when i took it
off and i was so happy to get that thing
off
luckily this was the only hiccup in
nicki's transformation into rosalie her
natural
flawless and vixenesque look was
completely in line with bella's
description of her in the book
describing her as beautiful figure the
kind you saw on the cover of the sports
illustrated swimsuit issue
we're happy about this casting and that
nikki reed walked away from the saga
with a full head of hair
do you need some help i could do her
hair
taylor lautner didn't know what he was
auditioning for without prior knowledge
of what exactly he was auditioning for
taylor lautner was cast as werewolf
jacob black with the understanding that
twilight was
vampires and you're in a forest we're
glad he bit
and took the roll it's hard to imagine
anyone else we'd want to see rip off
their shirt and run into the forest
while taylor's character description
didn't include his washboard abs it did
include a description of him having long
hair
pulled back in a rubber band like nikki
reed taylor also jumped
on the wig wagon in order to match this
description while his long hair drove
the audience mad
apparently the wig drove him mad tell me
what's your first
number he went on record saying
the wig it was a very important co-star
right now i'm not missing much there was
hatred between both of us
it did not like me and i did not like it
not fond memories
luckily for taylor's sanity the wig
didn't last long and his short hair was
a definite thirst trap for the remainder
of the saga
it was the grin jacob just going for a
ride esme cullen is the vampire mother
of our dreams
elizabeth reeser was cast perfectly
acting as mother to edward esme cullen
is described in the books as having the
same pale
beautiful features as the rest of the
vampires something about her
heart-shaped face
her billows of soft caramel colored hair
reminded me of the ingenues of the
silent movie era
she was small slender yet less angular
more rounded than the others pairing
that description next to a photo of
elizabeth reeser we can see the casting
motivation for the role especially with
her hair curled
elizabeth truly became esme i think that
went well
clean this up no unlike the other actors
on this
list the casting for sweet little
renesmee cullen was anything but sweet
in the book she's described as having
thick curls that were blood color and a
creamy pale face with fiery cheeks
and pink lips er while mackenzie foy was
definitely a cute
kid dracula 1 and 2 are creepy
she did not live up to our expectations
as renesmee on top of this the odd cgi
decisions did not help the case
rather than having a glittery look like
her dad renesmee had an almost
rainbow shimmer about her overall
renesme's casting definitely fell flat
it was really important to have a very
specific looking
little girl peter faucinelli was a lot
older than we expected as the adoptive
father of edward
carlisle is portrayed in the book as
being so good looking that he actually
stuns bella the first time they meet and
makes her question her motivation to be
with edward while peter faccinelli did a
great job fitting the role
i knew who i wanted to be i wanted to
help people
the audience was anticipating someone in
their 20s and comparatively attractive
compared to edward
if things had been different and peter
was cast alongside charlie swann we
would have for sure
been team dad for this actor one thing
peter did nail
the blonde hair and so they had to do
wigs and i
hate wearing them dakota fanning did not
meet the mark
dakota fanning acted great but wasn't a
character match
portraying jane the high-ranking volturi
guard vampire we had high hopes that she
would match up with bella's description
in the book the newcomer was as tiny as
alice with lenk pale brown hair trimmed
short the body under the cloak which was
darker
almost black was slim and androgynous
but the face was too pretty for a boy
the wide-eyed full-lipped face would
make a bocelli angel look like a
gargoyle
yeah anyone who's ever seen dakota
fanning knows that that is not at all an
accurate description
luckily her acting chops saved the day
and we were all on board
with her feisty character the volturi
don't give second chances
portraying one of the main villains
victoria on the big screen was disliked
by fans
not only because of her opposition to
bella but because of the disastrous
casting of not one but two versions of
victoria
you don't trust me michelle lefevre was
first up to bat as victoria falling
short of matching the long red hair and
sharp eyes that was reflected in the
original character design
due to scheduling issues rochelle was
replaced by bryce dallas howard who
didn't quite make the cut either
while her hair was definitely more in
line the actress transition was
difficult for fans to overlook
well the circumstances around it had
nothing to do
with us bella's bff and right-hand gal
pal ashley green was a near-perfect
choice to play the quirky and sweet
vampire
and adopted sister to edward and his
sibs while her sharp elf-like features
were on point with the original
intention of the film
fans weren't quite on board with her
haircut and especially the age
difference between the actress and her
on-page character with ashley coming
across as more of a young adult and less
of a late teen
it may not have been a complete copy but
overall we are happy with the casting
no smudging my masterpiece ah she's
right
that concludes our cast and character
comparison of the twilight saga we've
run through who matched and who the
casting directors should have swiped
left on
do you agree with our points on today's
video let us know in the comments below
who you thought was the best and worst
character match
while you're down there don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for all your
nostalgia content on the things
you